it's only had one win but the last two
starts as gary mentioned
have been very good only giving up two
runs he's got to keep the ball down he's
been throwing
much better and the last start was
outstanding
porcello's a guy who's always going to
give up more hits than anything's
pitched
mullins advances to second base sends up
renato nunez
2-0 pitch and a little looper
and it gets into right field for a base
hit around third comes mullins
darting to the plate here comes the
throw head first slide and he's in
with the first run of the game so nunez
with little looper
just beyond the reach of cano and the
orioles take a one-nothing lead
man at the corners one out mount castle
he also homered last night
and there's another one base hit into
center field nunez scores the orioles up
two nothing the rbi from ryan modcastle
so make it five straight games he's
driven in a run
well that'll put a smile on your face
won't it they'll take their swings off
of jorge lopez
obviously from puerto rico former second
round pick by the brewers back in 2011
player of puerto rican heritage today in
baseball he is wearing roberto
clemente's number 21.
two ground balls to the third baseman to
begin the bottom of the first inning
and it'll bring up j.d davis who is the
mets third baseman
oh right back at you good glove there
and a quick three outs that's down one
two three in the first orioles on top
two nothing
porcello goes to work against chance
cisco the baltimore catch you to start
the second inning two nothing orioles in
the first pitch line deep to right down
the line
and it is a fair ball ricochets into the
corner picked up by conforto fires to
second kanoa sweep
tag and he is out at second base what a
throw by conforto what a tag by
cano and what a questionable decision to
try to get to second base
so runners at the corners now one out
and a hot hitter particularly in the
power department now
jeff mcneal coming up one two to mcneil
and the breaking ball pulled into right
field for a base hit that brings in dom
with the first med run alonzo turns
second he's going to try for third
stuart's throw is cut off and alonso
makes it easily
rbi single for jeff mcneal gets the mets
on the board it's now two to one
multiple
rio ruiz digs in two on baltimore top of
the third with one out
here's the pitch to rio and he slams
this one the gap and left center field
it's going to take a bounce and go up
against the wall dj store will score
mount castle rounding third and he will
score
it's a two-run double for rio ruiz
and it's 4-1 baltimore
and there's a line drive into center
field that's a base hit from alberto
around third scoring is ruiz and the
orioles
got the bats booming again tonight 5-1
the birds now with 10 hits and we're
just in the third inning
and lopez continues to throw strike one
continues to get ahead
of course lopez has that two seamer that
he can start
in off the plate the left-handers and
just kind of leak it right back over the
plate
comes the o2 and he got him well that is
just perfect
two outs of runner on first as mcneal
bats
pitch neal to high drive toward deep
left mount castle goes back forward he's
in front of the wall he leaps and it's
gone
a home run opposite field homer for jeff
mcneill
and this becomes a two-run game the
baltimore league cut to 5-3
as mcneal has homer in a career-high
four straight games
and the mets badly needed this and this
situation right here
is basically built for chase and shreve
keep it close now it's 5-3
baltimore d.j stewart two for two
tonight
fly ball right field way back there and
this one
is gone are you kidding me upstairs
dj stewart now five homers in his last
four games
jason shreve had not given up a hit to a
left-hand hitter
all year long dj stewart didn't care and
the orioles get
one back in the top of the fifth with a
6-3 lead now
and forto has flied out and grounded
down and forto drives one out to right
center and that ball's going to fly out
of here
by michael conforto his eighth of the
year to get the mets back within two
runs
and now it's six to four baltimore but
that ball is scalded
and so the mets now runners at the
corners two out and robinson canoe will
be the go ahead and run at the plate
and he lights one up the middle of base
hit that'll bring in davis
smith stops at second canoe snaps out of
the old for 19 with an rbi single and
the mets trim the baltimore lead to a
skinny run
in six to five orioles already have a
dozen hits in this game
and that's hooked in the air to left a
long run for mcneal toward the line and
he made the catch oh wow what a play
by jeff mcneal crashing into the
sidewall
after reeling that ball in after a very
long run
a walk and two hit batsman loads up the
bases with two out justin wilson will
pitch to rio ruiz
and he drives one out to right field
chasing conforto back to the warning
track over his head and he made the kick
oh my gosh
michael conforto saves three runs with a
remarkable play
it was over his head it hit the glove
it popped up he caught it a second time
and he saves three runs
jimenez has seen a total of four pitches
and recorded two outs
jimenez drives one out to left mount
castle going back to the warning track
and it's in
here andres jimenez ties the game
with an opposite field home runs and the
mets have tied the game at
six and six
alonso leading off he's two for three
tonight he launches one out to center
field mullins going back to the warning
track at the wall it's out of here
alonso gives the mitch the lead with a
lead-off home run in the bottom of the
eighth
on the first pitch thrown by harvey and
the mitts lead for the first time
tonight
it's 7-6 new york
to try to save it is edwin diaz
and cisco grounds one of the right side
and jimenez with the roll over
guillermo makes the play that was
guillorme
playing on the right side of the bag
with a beautiful rollover move
so two men away as mullins steps in two
out of five in this game
2-1 coming to mullins and he popped it
up
jimenez waiting for it to come down and
the ball game is over
put it in the box oh what a win for the
new york mets
the new york mets 7 and the baltimore
orioles 6.